there's no doubt in my mind that you are
going to kill it and that's what I want
to talk about today
pee pee I really want to talk about this
patience and passion let's start with
passion there is way too many people in
this room right now that are doing stuff
they hate please stop doing that there
is no reason in 2015 to do [ __ ] you hate
none promise me you won't because you
can lose just as much money being happy
as hell clap that off because it's a
real [ __ ] how do you get money to do
what you love you don't write
I lost a shitload of money when I
started doing what I loved what you do
is you position yourself to succeed so
for example if you're doing something
else at you and you want to do this
thing you love you do it after hours you
work nine to six you get home you kiss
the dog and you go to town right I mean
you start building your equity in your
brand and whatever you're trying to
accomplish after hours you everybody has
time stop watching [ __ ] house of
cards that's a good overheard right that
was a good overheard so you know what I
mean I mean if you want this if you want
bling bling if you want to buy the Jets
if you want to do [ __ ] work that's how
you get it
so I got there's just nothing else to
say